[Music]
let's turn to our last
topic today in this week's spectator
wolfgang munchau
writes about what he calls the most
controversial gas
pipeline in the world it certainly is
it's called nordstrom 2
and would directly supply natural gas
from russia to germany
european leaders are furious at the
plans while biden's secretary of state
anthony blinken said
he's going to do whatever he can to stop
its completion
so why is germany sidling up to russia
how will it
change the eu's relationship with the us
uh wolfgang is director of euro
intelligence many of you remember when
he wrote
excellent columns for the financial
times he joins us now
wolfgang thanks for being on spectator
tv just give us before we come to the
issues that are making the headlines at
the moment
just give us a bit of background to how
nordstrom 2 came into effect
well it all happened with um with um
angela merkel's decision to cut off the
nuclear power
industry in 2011 she decided to face to
accelerate the phase out
and that made germany more dependent on
gas and
oil for its energy consumption and
germany is a country with
a lot of manufacturing industries so it
has a very large demand
for energy compared to most countries of
its size
and the only country that was able to
the only source of energy that was
readily available was gas
gas from russia and the idea of north
stream too it's a pipeline that goes
from
uh from the russian end of the baltic
sea through
swedish danish waters into germany has
been to
supply gas directly from russia to
germany bypassing ukraine
critically enough and that has been one
of the reasons why the u.s
administration has been so critical of
this project
and of course because it makes germany
even more dependent on you
on russian gas than it already is and
the the problem right now is that
germany actually is already dependent on
russian gas because what happens if
germany were to
yield to u.s demands and stop the
pipeline
for example in protest against the
arrest of navalny
um then the russians have threatened to
cut off germany from its existing
supplies and that could
conceivably produce an acute energy
crisis right now
so this is a real sort of almost life
and death issue for the german
government and they
are going to some extreme measures to
make sure that this russian gas is
flowing
and that this pipeline is uh the
construction of the pipeline is
completed
the polish response to the the problem
of gas supplies was to
build a number of new lng um
harbors places where lng can be
offloaded this a lot of it coming from
the united states which is now a major
gas
exporter was that never considered an
option
for germany yes the germans have
considered the option they have even
offered to build a terminal
what has emerged this week is that the
german finance minister
has actually offered to to spend a whole
billion euros
uh on on constructing an lng
terminal uh the the problem is is that
the existing lng terminals
in europe are not fully utilized in any
case um
and from an american point of view um
the
the issue is is that you know it's the
dependence on russian gas once this
pipeline is flowing there won't be much
demand
for lng um lng is a more complicated
technology this stuff has to be you know
it's liquid it has to be you know turned
into it's more expensive to move around
yes it's it's it's it's so so the
the issue is not the germans think it's
it's commercial the germans think the
americans just want to sell their lng to
them instead of you know
this isn't this is not a fair
characterization of the american
position
for the american this is a strategic
thing as well because because you know
germany is a is dependent um it's part
of nato
it's uh but it makes itself dependent uh
on
on russia so this is the american
position it's not only the republican
administration's position it was the
position of the trump administration
but it is a bipartisan majority in
congress that has passed
a law in 2019 to stop
uh to to impose sanctions on companies
involved in this project
and and the republicans and the biden
administration
seems intent from what we know so far to
um
to follow this uh follow this law and
use this law
so just to to to categorize the
geopolitical concern about this pipeline
at base is it a concern
that uh germany will be if
for a chunk of its energy needs it will
be dependent on russia
and that that will make it more
cozy with russia it would be less likely
to stand up to russia
at times when nato and the west and
germany's allies
need to stand up to russia is that the
fundamental concern
that is indeed the fundamental concern
and
what i would add to this con is that
this situation has already arisen i do
not think germany is at this moment
willing already to stand up to russia
because it is dependent on russia
already and this pipeline will make it
more dependent and there are also
political links between the social
democratic party in germany
and russia we remember that gerhard
schroeder the former chancellor
is the supervisory board chairman of the
north stream 2
project he's a personal friend of putin
he once called putin
a first-rate democrat um
so he is a you know the social
democratic leadership including the
president of germany frank walterstein
is also very close to russia and has and
this week
said that the pipeline was something
that germany owed to russia
because of the second world war um the
social democrat-run state of mecklenburg
four permanent this is the state in the
in the northeastern part of germany has
um
accepted money from the north stream ii
company
to build a foundation which serves as a
as a as a as an as a as a way to
circumvent u.s sanctions because this
your sanctions are not directed against
state and government-owned
entities so they are playing hardball
to have to to put this mindfully
i've been reading you your excellent uh
article in this week's spectator
wolfgang it does seem that there's
there's a there's a russian lobby at the
heart of the german political
elite would is that unfair to say that
and if it's not unfair why is there this
russian lobby
the russian lobby is is um has a long
tradition it
is um it's it is there is a a committee
called the east
the east committee of the german economy
and that committee is very powerful
compared to the national rifle
association in the united states in
terms of its influence and
in the german and in german business it
has a interesting thing
it it includes a lot of companies
especially you know the
people who've been exporting to russia
now they have complained bitterly about
the sanctions that germany you know
mackel
to her credit she she you know she uh
was
instrumental in in in organizing these
european sanctions against russia
but she also made sure that these
sanctions wouldn't become too
you know would not extend to to energy
so these sanctions are relatively
wouldn't say symbolic but they are not
as big as they could be or should be
and these people are now uh you know are
putting there's a
massive lobby an industrial lobby that
you know that's influential in the spd
parts of the cdu the so the christian
democrat michael's party
uh the csu uh so these are the parties
that are most
most likely to be you know you know
having these these links to russia
uh the party that is the least likely or
that is most
opposed to nordstrom the actually the
only party that is opposed to nordstrom
are the greens
and we have this extraordinary position
that the us position and the position of
the green party in germany are
completely aligned
uh that hasn't happened before indeed
the the role of gerhard schroeder
former former social democratic
chancellor of germany
his role looking from the outside
just seems extraordinary i i mean
alex salmon former first minister of
scotland he
he was beyond the pill because he
presents a
a program on what we used to call russia
today
that's all you just pray and he's no
longer an active politician
uh gerhard schroeder's relationship with
mr putin and the kremlin
i find it hard to think that any british
public figure
could survive what gerhard schroder has
done
well the thing is gertrude you know
survival is no longer in the
a matter for german politics or for
germany
the german public is reacting similarly
to that
this is not this is not accepted this is
not an accepted standard there is no law
against this
the government has since
sharpened the procedures against
politicians leaving government into you
know
getting into the employment of some some
someone
but in in general there is a you know
this is assumed to be
uh his choice um and
um uh one would assume that the united
states would have
would also not be able to stop mr trump
from acting
the way he will act or wants to act
after his presidency there
there are certainly he hasn't described
putin's pressure
as a well-functioning democracy but i
understand
mr schroeder's come quite close to that
he has he has he
um he has i mean he he's a personal
friend of putin putin came to his
birthday
and you know they are they have been
close on a person on a personal level
but even michael he was not close to
putin you know when they meet they speak
russian
um it's it's you know there is a deep
understanding in german
in german certainly in the german
society or in the sort of political
society
of russia russia is a country that
germans understand quite well
if you know if you look at eu countries
you know
the understanding of russia is is fairly
high in germany relative to that of
of other countries and there is a a link
i mean i always
think the germans look at russia the way
the dutch look at germany
it's sort of the the smaller the smaller
country looking at the bigger country
and sort of
in a mixture of fear and admiration and
you know that's
the relationship that that that the two
countries have had
historically the other the other
geopolitical significance that comes out
of your your uh article
wolfgang is that you we all assume
that with the departure of trump and
with a a
more traditional american president back
in the
white house a pro-nato transatlantic
uh president that that would mark a
reset of european
american relations there would still be
arguments there always are there were
arguments
under clinton arguments going back to
eisenhower
under reagan but that it would be reset
in a more
normal way it is possible is it not that
the row of this pipeline
is going to be a huge spanner in the
works of that
i would think so the biden
administration will change the tone and
that's already changed the tone towards
germany
and but mackel herself has concluded
that the and
i think rightly concluded that trump
isn't wasn't defeated in the last
election you know trump was defeated the
there was a clear election result but it
was a narrow election result
trump got some 70 million plus votes
um this uh you know the trumpism is
still there it might return
so germany has concluded that and for
along with france that they needed to be
you know autonomous in terms of its
foreign policy this is not you know as a
description of the status today
because they are not autonomous but it's
certainly a long-term policy goal
uh to become less dependent on the
united states uh
but they are still dependent on the
united states so we are in this sort of
position where these sort of ambitions
and the reality are
um a part
final question for you wolfgang
despite the biden administration's
dislike of this pipeline and
many of you i mean the british don't
like it either i think there's quite a
few european allies and not
at all keen on the eu's i understand it
isn't that keen on it
either but despite all that is it too
late
to stop now is is the pipeline
happening going to happen almost close
to a done deal
um it's it's they the germans were quite
optimistic in december that they could
get this done there was this the ship
this russian pipeline vessel which was
dispatched
to to um to to complete the remaining
you know five percent
but the problem that has arisen is that
companies
in charge of certifying of safety
certification
have refused to uh to actually do the
job
because they are subject to u.s
sanctions and as of now there is no plan
b
for uh for that there is no no no no
company available
willing willing to do this now they
might come up with something so it is a
bit of a race against the time
the idea is to complete the remaining
five percent
and get the stuff switched on before the
americans do anything
but so far this isn't happening and the
interesting when i speak to both sides
is both sides are absolutely convinced
that their position will ultimately
prevail the americans are absolutely
convinced that they will stop it
and in germany virtually everybody is
telling you that
gas will flow in the end so you know
somebody will
in the end lose out and at the moment i
think
that you know my my hunch is that that
it will flow at reduced rates that that
will be the compromise at some point
but this won't be easy to work so there
may be some
some kind of compensation payment that
germany pays to russia or something like
that
there is a compromise possible because
you can the amount of gas your sensory
pipeline is
um you know is one can regulate it so
that would probably be or a that is a
possible compromise
okay well the story is not over yet
wolfgang we'll come back to you as it
develops
for the moment wolfgang director of euro
intelligence uh
thank you for your call in the spectator
this week and thank you for appearing on
spectator tv
[Music]
you